le problème c'est qu'on prête qu'aux
riches et on a de nombreux motifs de se
méfier de ce que fait la république en
marche depuis le début si c'était vous
voyez si ça venait d'un pouvoir vous
vous présentez à paris à la tête des
mets paris un petit parti qu'est ce que
c'est ok voilà est-ce que c'est
compliqué justement quand on est un
petit parti de faire campagne pour ces
municipales
bon on a des soutiens de partie plus
important évidemment c'est compliqué
parce que quand je reviendrai ensuite
sur le sujet donc qui nous préoccupe à
savoir la république en marche et c'est
pratique mais bon pari c'est 529
candidats peu ou prou voyez avec la
parité
donc c'est un système démentiel qui a
hérité en fait de gaston defferre en
1983 les premières élections municipales
avec quelque chose qui à mon sens
devrait être revu un peu aussi à
marseille ou à lyon à savoir qu'il ya
trop débuté il ya clairement trop d'élus
il ya eu en plus une séparation entre
les conseillers d'arrondissement et les
conseillers de paris qui n'est plus qui
n'est plus de ce monde enfin qu'il n'a
plus de raison d'être et donc tout ça
fait que on devrait avoir moins d'élus
et des beasty ce qu'ils soient plus
compact et ça serait beaucoup plus
visible alors ça c'est le premier à vous
parler d'un recul dans l'archi alors la
république aux marches le problème le
problème c'est que on est habitué aux
manipulations au fait de se présenter
parfois sous des étiquettes et des
couleurs ambigu au fait d'essayer de
débaucher l'ordre quand on voit par
exemple les pratiques de monsieur
griveaux à paris vous voyez qui va
essayé de débaucher des maires sortants
ou d'anciens maires aussi mais en parti
socialiste que en fait à droite avec
avait avec delphine bürkli dans le 9e
enfin et c'est du débauchage parce que
c'est vraiment mais si on est face à un
pouvoir qui a l'habitude de la
manipulation dont ils viennent fois
qu'ils viennent de ce pouvoir qui nous
permettait de terminer et ensuite vous
pourrez me répondre autant que vous le
souhaitez donc quoi qu'il vienne de ce
pouvoir c'est le problème du de
l'individu qui a déjà volé et ensuite
dont on se méfie vous voyez eh bien il a
mauvaise réputation et monsieur n'à qu'à
son prépuce est reparti on
salvatore de fuir il n'ya il faut pas
prendre pour l'instant même temps
s'interroge pas sur ses motivations à
une élévation attendait sur monsieur les
motivations de la république en marche
on les comprend très bien on ce dont on
parle là c'est de la technique et du de
mode opératoire et les voisins collègues
sur la mode opératoire moi je maintiens
que cette circulaire était voulu moi
même je suis encore jusqu'aux prochaines
municipales conseiller du une ville
qu'on se dise pas d'une ville de 8 500
habitants dans le pas de calais j'avais
été élu sous l'étiquette socialiste à
l'époque il y avait dix membres du parti
socialiste sur une liste de 29 non il y
avait dix neuf membres de la société
civile qu'on à qui on impose et
l'étiquette parti socialiste à la
préfecture parce que tous les élus sont
déclarés comme étant élu du parti
socialiste étaient au départ comme à un
blessé le formulaire pour savoir quel
est le nom de la liste et à quelles fins
six blessés dans les tirs de tête de
l'érection
si c'est bon j'ai eu quand même rempli
un certain nombre de formulaires cerfa
dans ma vie on va dire de déclaration de
candidature donc c'est très clair et les
gens qui se présentent des élections
savent très bien en plissant le
formulaire en signant la formule
sacramentelle
ils savent qu'elle est la tête de liste
et donc ils savent parfaitement quelle
couleur politique et leur invention très
bien comment ça fonctionne dans l'est
dans les pratiques un peu douteuse mais
la pratique c'est de savoir pourquoi les
français